bueno evidentemente es la cara y la cruz
la cara evidentemente son los millones
de simpatizantes que hoy han votado por
resettahiperdogan y recibían
evidentemente la noticia con una gran
alegría de hecho antes incluso de que se
declarase que oficialmente resetea y
perdón era el ganador de estas
elecciones había gente que ya lo estaba
celebrando en las calles se podían
escuchar claxones en las calles los
coches circulaban
celebrándolo las plazas empezaban a
llenarse de gente antes incluso de
esperar la noticia de que oficialmente
era ganador ahora mismo como os podéis
imaginar No sé si se puede escuchar el
ambiente en algunos momentos hay muchos
claxones de coches que están
celebrándolo se puede escuchar
perfectamente la plaza de taxim de hecho
ahora mismo es un hervidero de gente que
lo está celebrando y por otra parte la
cruz la oposición ha recibido la noticia
de esta derrota una derrota que los
sondeos no vaticinaban ellos mismos no
se esperaban que pudiesen perder en
estas elecciones lo dijeron durante toda
la campaña era Ahora o nunca y
finalmente se ha confirmado que la
oposición tendrá que seguir trabajando
para conseguir una futura Victoria que
no será antes de 5 años por lo tanto
desolación entre la oposición por esta
derrota de hoy